okay has anyone caught the um
the problem with the logic this is an
algebraic problem
actually okay have you you're
not minusing uh one solid from
another you should do it separately and
when you put it together you should
square it
but why why because it just is
this is exactly the explanation i am
trying to avoid clemens because the
slices
ah this is promising okay before i go
after that which organization
can you redraw the diagram sure i can
okay
i probably shouldn't have wiped it off
actually but anyway let's see how
quickly i can do it
i only want this part
the volume of this whole shape which is
like a cylinder with a cone cut out of
it
you're talking about shifting this up or
the whole thing you mean just this part
here
but yeah you'll get you get a thicker
rim if you like if you did that
we're going to do that question in a
minute does that relate to this
kind of kinda
it's a little tenuish i think clemen's
onto something here
okay now let's have a think about this
right
for starters for starters what is this
going to give you
three minus x and then you square it
okay well let's just compare it to our
like if i consider this as a volume okay
so if i go pi a to b of y squared dx
what's the y
in this case well that's three minus x
now what's that
it's a straight line right and it's this
straight line
okay three minus x so that's why it goes
down like that
okay now when you rotate this you get
the same shape that we've been seeing
already this is a cone
backwards this is not a um
a current cut out of a cylinder it's
just a current
right which is why you get this
equivalence
okay so you're like oh okay that sort of
makes sense
but but why algebraically doesn't work
okay i'll show you
um it was all in this this line here
okay this is where the problems start
there were no problems after that
right why is this not equivalent to
doing this
okay why is subtracting these two worked
out things different from subtracting
first
okay can anyone see
um what is this thing right um this is
one volume
let's call it pi now in our case we use
the cylinder formula because we knew it
was a cylinder
right but we know that we can get a
cylinder from doing our normal volumes
of solids of revolution right
so let's call it this that uh
what should i call it let's call it y
one
dx and that thing got squared so there's
one point
okay here's the other one it's pi same
boundaries
but it's a different function that's
squared
okay now when i take the difference of
these and get this number
or rather this line what does that mean
okay
it's one integral
minus another integral now what's in
common between these integrals
the domain is in common and the pi is in
common so i i'm happy to combine those
let's go up and step down okay so this
is now what i've got
there's one and there's the other okay
now do you see it
now do you see the algebraic formula
what have i done here what have i tried
to do
i i did y 1 minus y 2 and then i squared
right but that's quite obviously not
equal to this
okay does that make sense so you see
what algebraically
it doesn't hold water okay so even
though it's like oh this is nice and
fast
oh it doesn't work okay so i always had
problems with this explaining like why
can you do it with area
you can't deal with volume can anyone
tell me you know what in a sentence
why can't i why can't i do it with are
even not volumes
because you must square first yes
exactly right the square is the problem
right the square is the problem
if i'm taking the difference between two
integrals just two integrals no problems
you can combine however you like
okay but if one square if they're both
squared you can't put them together and
then squared because
you'll just get a different value at the
end does that make sense
okay can we just start if they ask us to
find that sort of body can we start
writing
like this can you start writing it like
this
okay the answer is yes the answer is yes
okay i think there are good reasons
still
to write it out in full form i you're
probably so sick so definitely saying
this but why do you think it might be a
good idea
to write out like this rather than
jumping straight here can anyone tell
you all three
because it brings in errors okay the
more things you skip the more places for
errors to creep in and it's like i
didn't even know that i got it wrong
because i jump straight to this line
now in particular the area that creeps
in is um
the algebra gets mixed up in here
because there's simplification
okay but it's still a worthwhile thing
to do like later on
in this case putting them together
wouldn't have given us that many
benefits
okay um but if there was like x's in
here and x in here that are in common or
maybe cancel out
it starts to get drastically simpler
okay so i think this is where you
eventually want to end up you know being
able to be comfortable writing that and
not getting any errors creeping into
your working
okay but work out the volume separately
in fact
where you've got this diagram okay i'd
like to put in big capital red letters
work out the volumes separately okay
or volumes work out yeah i can't think
of a short way to write okay
work out the volume separate write it
like three times if you have to
so that you get if you don't do that if
you try to do the shortcut
it kind of explodes on you okay
all right now let's do um i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna write it all out okay i'm
just gonna ask you
and then i'll let you go for the
exercise right what would change
if i wanted to um suppose i didn't like
this shape that i made
okay because it's got these sharp edges
at the tops right you're like if i drink
this i'm going to cut myself right
so instead what i'm doing
yeah that's right well you could drink
it right i take this same internal
volume
okay and i say i want to make the rim
where you where i put my lip okay
i want to make it a bit wider okay say a
unit wide
okay so i'm still going to do a rotation
right what am i going to get
this now up here that's the area that
i'm going to rotate
okay so it's going to come down here as
well
so i want to get this now there's that
circle
okay but now that it's got a rim okay um
it's going to have this kind of shape
around there's a doughnut at the top if
you like if you're looking at it from
the top down
okay and then this part is still
cylindrical at the bottom
okay now what changes what changes
um has the internal volume changed
answered no it's still going to be the
same old curve
or whatever other kind of shape it is
the difference is just a cylinder
okay um the specifically the radius
of the cylinder yeah so if i were to
work this out
what single number would i change
in this working um i just changed this
right
uh wait no so that's that's fine uh
this is the radius okay and that'll just
reflect across
okay so um you'll get those kinds of
questions quite
frequently uh in fact they're more
common than the first one i gave you
that's kind of reached it's very useful
okay so in that case just
adjust your cylinder and that's why
that's this is one of the actual reasons
why that's useful
um jumping to this line sometimes
obscures that okay